Нейронні мережі — це потужний клас алгоритмів машинного навчання
і вони бувають різних видів
у вступному відео неможливо приділити належну увагу нейронним мережам
на кшталт цього
тут ми лише виділимо кілька ключових компонентів
нейронної мережі та загальний робочий процес
щоб зрозуміти, як квантові обчислення можуть зробити внесок
нейронна мережа — це зв'язний граф нейронів
нейрон — це, по суті, просто щось, що зберігає число
і це число часто називають активацією — наскільки
нейрон увімкнений або вимкнений
нейрони впорядковані у шари
перший шар — це вхідний шар
а останній — це вихідний шар
між ними є шари обробки, які називаються
прихованими шарами. Активація
вхідного шару завантажується безпосередньо з даних для аналізу
наприклад, з відтінків пікселів зображення
активації наступного прихованого шару визначаються
нейронами вхідного шару
та вагами, позначеними лініями, що з'єднують усі нейрони
вхідного шару з усіма нейронами
наступного шару. Тобто ми визначаємо активацію
нейрона в прихованому шарі
за допомогою зваженої суми всіх
вхідних активацій. Ми також можемо
застосовувати зміщення — зсув
можливо, ми захочемо активувати нейрон
у прихованому шарі не просто якщо зважена сума
додатна, а лише якщо вона перевищує певний великий поріг
потім ми часто застосовуємо складну функцію, щоб отримати активацію
від нуля до одиниці — наприклад, гіперболічний тангенс
або іноді інакше —
випрямлений лінійний блок. Не варто надто
перейматися цим зараз. Єдине,
що важливо зазначити про ці функції, —
вони є нелінійними
так що мережа в цілому містить як лінійні,
так і нелінійні компоненти
та сама зважена сума активацій, цього разу
починаючи з активацій
першого прихованого шару з новими вагами
поширюється до наступного прихованого шару
це продовжується аж до фінального шару, яким є вихідний
вихідний шар містить нейрони, що відповідають
категоріям, а активації показують нам
наскільки мережа впевнена у класифікації
так, вихідні категорії в аналізі зображень можуть бути
собака, кіт, хом'як і так далі
і активація 0,95 на
нейроні «собака» свідчитиме про високий ступінь впевненості в тому, що
на зображенні собака. Можливо, ти почнеш свою нейронну мережу
з випадковим набором ваг
і зміщень або з відомої розумної початкової конфігурації
але потім ідея полягає в тому, щоб перевірити
наскільки добре твоя нейронна мережа класифікує речі
і вдосконалити її. Для цього ми використовуємо функцію витрат, щоб описати
наскільки наша нейронна мережа відхиляється від
правильної класифікації. Це передбачає обчислення
різниці між реальним значенням зображення
наприклад, значенням 1 на нейроні
для «собаки» і 0 на всіх інших вихідних нейронах
та передбаченими значеннями
ми підсумовуємо по всіх категоріях
і відстежуємо не лише те, чи була правильна категорія
найбільш активованою, але й можемо
також відстежувати, чи зменшуються неправильні активації
підсумовуємо по всіх прикладах у нашому навчальному наборі
і отримуємо значення витрат. Потім ми
варіюємо параметри — наприклад, ваги в кожному шарі
між усіма нейронами та зміщення на кожному з них
для пошуку використовуються класичні алгоритми оптимізації
локального мінімуму функції витрат
якщо нічого не робити для зменшення складності цього
можеш уявити, який
астрономічний простір параметрів ми тут створили
розглянь нейронну мережу, призначену для аналізу зображень із
лише тисячею пікселів. Така нейронна мережа може мати тисячу
вхідних нейронів, лише один прихований шар
і двійковий вихід — наприклад, кіт або собака
це найпростіший випадок
і він все одно відповідає матриці тисяча на тисячу
тобто мільйон ваг між вхідним і прихованим шарами
і ще дві тисячі між
прихованим і вихідним шарами
плюс ще, можливо, тисяча
або близько того зміщень. Тобто ця проста нейронна мережа відповідала б
більш ніж мільйону параметрів. Хоча, якщо чесно,
сучасні алгоритми зазвичай використовують спрощення
у класичних нейронних мережах
і існують цілі напрями, присвячені тому, щоб зробити цю мінімізацію
можливою і навіть ефективною
але факт залишається фактом — це дуже
багатовимірна задача
і навчання нейронної мережі
може займати дуже багато часу
і коштувати дорого. Квантова нейронна мережа, або QNN,
працює шляхом спочатку завантаження вхідних даних
а потім застосування quantum circuits
що відповідають вагам між шарами
і нарешті шару вимірювання
кілька ключових моментів щодо цього: завантаження даних
та зважування — це лінійні операції
але вимірювання є нелінійними
отже, як і в класичних нейронних мережах, тут є
і лінійні, і нелінійні компоненти
крім того, weight circuits
все ще мають варіаційні параметри
тож класична мінімізація все одно є необхідною
звісно, це лише поверхневий огляд квантових нейронних
мереж, але ми сподіваємося, що ти продовжиш вивчати застосування
квантових нейронних мереж
та інші застосування квантового машинного навчання
разом з IBM Quantum